trait young of my Atlanta Hawks lost to
the Phoenix Suns last night but there
was a highlight moment there where he
nutmegged Ricky Rubio and for those of
you who've never done it or had it done
to you that's when somebody bounces the
ball through your legs and that's what
happened last night with Ricky Rubio
Trey that was not nice what you did to
Ricky Rubio last night have you had that
done to you
no thankfully not thankfully not I just
never ever to me but you knock on some
wood real quick okay
but this is what I'm concerned if you
miss with that kind of dribble then
somebody's gonna you're gonna hit him in
the Rubio's and then he's then somebody
gonna get upset at you Trey and that
happens but it doesn't happen yet it had
nothing yet so did you watch it did you
watch the football last night did I know
you had a game did you get a chance to
see what happened in the Browns and the
Steelers game yeah I got I got to see
what happened arrived to the game I saw
as everybody was talking about it so
yeah that's a game I saw that was crazy
crazy crazy moment crazy moment I know
that you have you been in a fight before
on the court I'm not on the court not on
the court no sir
wait off the court you have had they
wanted twice back in high school middle
school wait whose it was somebody
picking on you
very fresh very fresh vegan getting out
on the basketball court in grant
hopefully you didn't nutmeg somebody and
that's what led to a fight cuz I you
know I got to make sure that you stay
healthy this season how much fun are how
much fun is this season compared to last
season it's a lot more fun it's a lot
more fun it's uh it's been great I mean
I'm playing a lot starting off the
season a lot better than I did last year
which is good and it's been fun it's
been tough
a lot of our our guys out those that's
that's the only sad part and that part
about it so far but everything else has
been pretty good are you gonna be in the
three-point contest this year I don't
know I know no let me know about that oh
no you can get in I'm getting I'm gonna
extend the invitation on behalf of the
NBA
so if invited is trailing going to be in
the three-point [ __ ] yeah I mean I love
you I got invited so let's see that
could you beat Vince Carter in a dunk
contest right now at Vince's age
oh no no probably what contest is
everybody yeah I want to see I wouldn't
you love to see Vince being the slam
dunk contest what is he 42 yeah he's 42
I would love to hear I would love to see
him and don't contest that would do it
there why not this is probably as last
year he would get the sympathy vote
people would I mean you got a time to
him you got a say Vince you got to do
this man this would be epic I'll try
I'll try to put in a put in a worse yeah
I'm sort of nowhere
how many dunks do you have in prizes if
we're talking about practice I got a lot
oh you do but in the game no in the game
I got I got zero I got zero
I thought you almost had one last year
against Cleveland does that sound right
I think maybe in transition yes I think
I had that was my chance I was my
opportunity you got the Clippers and the
Lakers coming up what's the scouting
report on the Clippers I mean horizon
Paul George's first game together so
it'll be something new I mean I don't I
don't know they say we haven't talked
about it but that's gonna be something
new and then the Lakers obviously you
guys try to stop the the big guy a deep
down low and then I try to contain
LeBron as much as you can so now you
don't have to you don't have to worry
about
either those two guys yeah yeah yeah I
do I got it
I gotta figure out where they're passing
it to but you you'll have Beverly
probably guarding you when you face the
Clippers won't you so I said I'll
probably have Paul in quiet a little bit
too so yeah but Beverly's a pest though
he wants you to get he wants to agitate
you right yeah yeah he does he does a
tiny place but do you care
like what do you want that does that
kind of get you more competitive yeah I
mean I mean it doesn't really I mean
like I mean I don't I don't mind it I
don't mind it that's how that's how you
guys play I have to figure out a way to
to uh use it to my advantage so I mean
that's not he mr. Garvey I gotta find a
way to use it what do you do all day
it's 8:30
la time so you got what shoot around
what do you do the rest of the day
before you play the Clippers tomorrow
we've had a lot of games on the road so
today's our first actually all day on
this road trip
so um really just get some relaxed time
I got some family in town so spend some
time with them probably get one
Latanya this morning or later tonight
and then I'm just rest and get ready for
the bathtub right you ever gone out and
just practice by yourself yeah sure sure
all the time like if there was a court
right around the corner from your hotel
and you saw some kids out there did you
run it with them I would pick up with
them but I probably walk over there yeah
it starts up and just just hang out with
them a little bit it'd be nice if you
went in full uniform and then you'd just
you know went out there and took a
couple of jump shots
you don't like uncle drew where you just
went out there and you put on a little
bit of a show yeah that's pretty cool
maybe you could get a dunken during a
game
first year I have one of them you could
poster eyes a 12 year old I think that
would be that'd be great
hey it's it's been fun don't be afraid
to pick up a victory here you know all
right I got you I got you sounds good
thank you all right Thank You Trey
that's a tray young of my Atlanta Hawks
wing car
averaging 27 nine not bad yapple use
tell Trey young don't be afraid to pick
up my headphones cut out yeah don't be
afraid to pick up a victory checkers on
gotta keep them straight here here for
more Dan Patrick show tune into audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]